guttenburg meine damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen schön sie
wiederzusehen
schön sie wohl auch wieder zu sehen die
sitzung ist hiermit eröffnet sie haben
ja auch schon platz genommen
bevor wir in unsere tagesordnung auch
eintreten gibt es eine amtliche
mitteilung in der fraktion l wurde
vereinbart den gesetzentwurf zur
stärkung des schutzes der bevölkerung
und insbesondere wollen europa
personengruppen vor witz 19 auf
drucksachen 25 73 auch dem
wirtschaftsausschuss zur mit beratung zu
überweisen sind sie damit einverstanden
dass es offenkundig der fall ich sehr
kräftiges die gehen dann ist der
gesetzentwurf zur mit beratung an den
wirtschaftsausschuss auch überwiesen
ich hoffe nun auf unseren
tagesordnungspunkt 1 a und 1 b die erste
beratung ist von der bundesregierung
eingebracht gebrachten entwurfs eines
gesetzes über die feststellung des
bundes haushaltsplanes für das haushalts
jahr 2023 und die beratung des
finanzplans des bundes 2022 bis
im rahmen der haushaltsberatungen sind
für die heutige aussprache im anschluss
an die 20 minütige einbringung des
haushalts sieben stunden für mittwoch 8
stunden für donnerstag 9 stunden und 39
minuten sowie für freitag drei stunden
vorgesehen
ich sehe sie sind auch damit
einverstanden mit diesem ambitionierten
plan und dann verfahren mir auch so und
dann eröffne ich auch die aussprache und
das wort zur einbringung des
hat der parlamentarische staatssekretär
beim bundesministerium der finanzen herr
doktor florian toncar
auch präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen zunächst darf
ich sie um verständnis bitten dass der
bundesminister lindner heute aufgrund
eines trauerfalls diese rede nicht
halten kann ich bin den fraktionen sehr
dankbar dass wir die möglichkeit
bekommen haben mit dem bundesminister am
donnerstag über den haushalt zu sprechen
dafür nochmal ganz herzlichen dank wir
alle stehen dann unter dem eindruck der
sehr berührende und tiefen rede von
staatspräsident isaac herzog der trotz
der beispiellosen verbrechen die
deutsche an juden begangen haben einen
engen gemeinsamen schulterschluss
israels und deutschlands angesichts der
herausforderungen der gegenwart und der
zukunft angeboten hat und ich denke wir
sollten dieses angebot in demut und
dankbarkeit annehmen hier
stehen wir für jede frage wie die
bundesrepublik und in europa in der welt
in einer
bewährungsprobe wie wir sie lange nicht
mehr erlebt haben die pandemie hat kraft
gekostet
physische kraft soziale kraft auch
finanzielle kraft und der russische
angriffe auf die ukraine hat eine völlig
neue lage geschaffen geschaffen wir
sehen den einsatz von energie als waffe
wir sehen den einsatz von hunger als
waffe wir erleben explodierenden
energiepreise und in deutschland eine
inflation im august von 7,9 prozent bei
gleichzeitig stark zurückgehen im
wirtschaftswachstum vieles im ungewissen
und insofern meine ich war oder sollte
der besuch von staatspräsident herzog
und seine rede hier heute für uns auch
anlass zu sein und es vielleicht einmal
damit auseinanderzusetzen wie ein land
der staat israel der seit 1948 im grunde
beständig fast tag für tag
herausgefordert wird der staatspräsident
sprach den anschlag an auch das
israelische olympiateam 1972 und aktuell
das iranische atomprogramm dieser staat
mit solchen bewährungsproben umgeht in
israel ist es stets gelungen und auch
schwierigsten druck von außen eine
vielfältige gesellschaft eine innovative
eine sehr leistungsfähige gesellschaft
zu erhalten dort weiß man und das habe
ich mir auf weil ich selbst letzte woche
noch in israel war auch noch einmal
eindrücklich zeigen lassen in
schwierigen zeiten ist es am
riskantesten nichts zu tun und alles so
lassen wie es ist ich glaube das können
wir von israel erneut mit dieser
bewährungsprobe und der ungewissheiten
zu gehen
eine solche sehr ungewisse lage die sich
natürlich auch ständig wechselt ständig
wandelt die bewältigt man dadurch das so
kurzfristig nötig gehandelt wird und
richtig gehandelt aber man überwindet
ihn dauerhaft nur dadurch dass wir die
gesellschaft modernisieren dass wir die
strukturellen probleme die bereits
vorher vorhanden waren in der krise erst
recht und beschleunigt angehen und genau
das ist auch das was wir jetzt in dieser
krise machen wir brauchen neue
lieferungen als ersatz für russische
gaslieferungen zum beispiel flüssiggas
wir bauen dafür entsprechende terminals
und wir lernen daraus schnellere
planungsprozesse sind nicht nur bei
flüssiggas wichtig sie sind auch für die
energiewende wichtig die digitalisierung
den wohnungsbau und die infrastruktur
und das regel kommt das und das ist
einfach wir lernen wir müssen in
deutschland in der lage sein
sanktioniert es vermögen zu erkennen und
auch einzufrieren wir ziehen daraus den
schluss dass es dabei auch nicht leid
muss sondern dass wir generell die
geldwäschebekämpfung in deutschland auf
eine neue grundlage stellen müssen so
wie es der bundesfinanzminister in der
letzten woche vorgeschlagen hat das ist
ein weitergehender schluss der dauerhaft
probleme ab stellt die vorher schon
daran und
wir stellen fest es gibt technologischen
abhängigkeiten von ländern von denen wir
nicht abhängig sein wollen und sein
sollten und wir ziehen daraus den
schluss wir brauchen eine strategie der
bundeswirtschaftsminister ist hier wir
brauchen ein zukunfts
finanzierungsgesetzes der
bundesfinanzminister mit dem
bundesjustizminister vorgeschlagen hat
um auch und gerade in den
technologiebasierten neuen
geschäftsfeldern in deutschland stärker
zu werden und das über den tag und über
diese krise hinaus
wir
haben sehr viele handlungsfelder wo die
modernisierung des landes angegangen
wird über den tag und die aktuelle
krisensituation hinaus und dennoch gibt
es sie und das größte aktuelle problem
in deutschland ist ohne jede frage die
inflation und ihre folgen sie
überfordert viele menschen schlichtweg
in finanzieller hinsicht sie raubt
menschen planungssicherheit
lebensplanung und damit auch freiheit
individuelle freiheit und inflation
gefährdet unternehmerischen erfolg
unserer gesellschaft im ganzen inflation
zu bekämpfen muss das oberste ziel
gerade auch der finanzpolitik sein und
natürlich
[Musik]
hat inflation die nur eine ursache aber
es ist wichtig zuerst an den ursachen
anzusetzen und dann folgen zu
finanzieren und deswegen ist es wichtig
für die bekämpfung von inflation
beispielsweise flüssiggas oder andere
alternative energiequellen zu
importieren es ist wichtig mit einem
modernen einwanderungsrecht dafür zu
sorgen dass wir mehr menschen haben sich
auch am arbeitsmarkt aktiv sind und die
engpässe die überall zu spüren sind auch
zu beseitigen genau das geht diese
koalition an ist es jahrelang nicht
passiert aber es ist nötig
und auch
das hat mit der bekämpfung von
inflations ursachen zu tun wir sollten
den handel mit befreundeten ländern
erleichtern deswegen werden wir das
freihandelsabkommen mit kanada
ratifizieren und damit einen beitrag
leisten dafür dass wir auch leichter an
ihm vorbeikommen können als bisher 2
der staat sollte inflationär situationen
nicht auch noch mit eigenen regeln die
preise nach oben treiben es ist ohne
jede frage so dass preise wirken müssen
dass sich preise bilden müssen und dass
preise auch dazu führen dass die
gesellschaft bestimmte dinge ändert zum
beispiel sparsamer mit energie
das ist dennoch muss man natürlich die
frage stellen ist es klug in einer
situation wo sich inflation aufbaut und
der an dem punkt sind wo sich
entscheidet ob sie bleibt oder ob sie
wieder sinkt in dem punkt wo es auf
inflationserwartungen ankommt auch noch
staatlicherseits preise zu treiben
deswegen haben wir die eeg umlage zum
ersten sieben abgeschafft um den
strompreis damit entlastet deswegen
deswegen haben wir beschlossen am
wochenende eine strompreis wenn sie die
in großem umfang und mit einem sozialen
schwerpunkt menschen entlasten wird von
den hohen strompreisen und deswegen
haben wir auch beschlossen die
staatliche co2 bereisung zu verschieben
all das soll dafür sorgen dass die
inflationserwartungen jetzt nicht noch
weiter steigen und dabei hält die
inflation auch wieder in den griff zu
bekommen
dennoch gibt es sie und deswegen müssen
wir natürlich auch dafür sorgen dass
ihre folgen
kompensiert werden wobei der staat ganz
sicher nicht alles kompensieren kann
aber wir haben ein beachtliches paket
von wenn man alles zusammenzählt über 95
milliarden euro in verschiedenen
schritten dieses jahr auf den weg
gebracht das ist äußerst beachtlich und
das zeigt auch wie leistungsfähig dieses
land ist in dem wir leben es geht dabei
um direkte hilfen für menschen die
besonders betroffen sind die besonders
stark unter den steigenden preisen
leiden das sind die empfänger von hilfen
das sind die empfänger von wohngeld das
sind familien das sind erwerbstätige
rentner pensionäre studenten und
familien und ich warne davor zu sagen
weil diesen gruppen mit
unterschiedlichen instrumenten helfen
das sei die gis kann denn es gibt es
gibt gerade auch in der mittelschicht
viele menschen die bezahlen ihre
stromrechnung selber die bezahlen ihre
gasrechnung selber und die brauchen
jetzt unterstützung aber es gibt nicht
immer dass eine einzige instrument mit
dem man alle erreichen kann und deswegen
ist es nötig mehrere nebeneinander
anzuwenden genau das tun wir weil wir
auch an die mittelschicht denken die
selbst mit dieser situation zur
angekommen muss
wir werden dafür sorgen dass die
menschen die steuern bezahlen nicht
durch die inflation faktischen einen
höheren steuertarif getrieben werden das
ist der ausgleich der kalten progression
wenn jemand der bisher 40.000 euro
verdient hat künftig durch die inflation
weiterhin 40.000 euro verdient aber
kaufkraft für 37.000 euro hat ist es
nicht richtig im mehr steuern
abzuverlangen als vorher bestraft man
die menschen doppelt indem man
einerseits die mit der inflation
natürlich erleben müssen und auf der
anderen seite höhere steuern abverlangt
genau das wollen wir ausgleichen genau
das ist unser faires angebot an die
mittelschicht und
insofern
haben wir uns mit einem wuchtigen paket
auch den folgen den erscheinungen dieser
hohen inflation gestellt
zu einer bekämpfung von inflation gehört
aber auch dass haushalte konsolidiert
werden das ist anders als in zeiten der
pandemie wo es richtig war eine
expansive fiskalpolitik zu betreiben
heute ziemlich konsens dass wir heute
keine expansive fiskalpolitik mehr
benötigen sondern eine planvolle
rückkehr zu sinkenden defiziten und auch
das ist zeitenwende denn es ist eine
andere ökonomische situation als noch in
der panini in deutschland bedeutet das
dass wir im jahr 2023 mit diesem
haushaltsentwurf zur regel grenze nach
der schuldenbremse zurückkehren werden
die schuldenbremse ist nicht irgend
etwas sie ist auch nicht im zeitraum
manchmal lesen darf ein fetisch oder
irgend etwas ähnliches sondern sie ist
im kern eine regel die mit
zweidrittelmehrheit im bundestag und
zwei drittel mehr im bundesrat in unser
grundgesetz geschrieben ist und
dementsprechend auch den respekt
verdient in eine regel im grundgesetz
verdient sie ist einzuleiten
man kann
politisch argumentieren sie auch wieder
zu ändern aber sie gilt und sie ist
nicht mit bestimmten worten
despektierlich
despektierlich zu warnen und ein
finanzminister der sich der einhaltung
des grundgesetzes verpflichtet fühlt
erfüllt nicht mehr und nicht weniger als
seinen amtseid liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und insofern ist der vorschlag der ihnen
vorlegt dass die neuverschuldung nach
215 4 milliarden im jahr 2021 maximal
38,9 milliarden in diesem jahr im
nächsten jahr auf 17,2 milliarden
abgesenkt wird das ist ein schwieriger
schritt das ist auch ein schritt der mit
konsolidierungsmaßnahmen verbunden ist
beispielsweise einer stelleneinsparung
von 1,5 prozent ausgenommen der
sicherheitsbereich der verbunden ist mit
einer globalen minderausgabe die alle
ressorts zu erbringen hat aber es ist
ein notwendiger schritt denn die
schuldenbremse hat ja einen sinn sie
soll zwei dinge leisten sie soll dafür
sorgen dass heutige generationen ihre
herausforderungen nicht in einer weise
lösen die künftigen generationen schwer
oder unmöglich macht die herausforderung
die sich ihnen irgendwann stellen wir
haben genauso gut in den griff zu
kriegen wie wir heute und die
schuldenbremse ist eine regel die
fundamental darauf ausgerichtet ist die
handlungsfähigkeit unseres staates und
damit auch die akzeptanz und stärke
unseres staates erhalten und dir das
letzte jahrzehnt ist ja ein gutes
beispiel dafür wir sind aus der
finanzkrise im jahr 2010 mit einem
schuldenstand gesamtstaatlich von etwa
80 prozent herausgekommen und im jahr
2019 der herr bundeskanzler als
damaliger finanzminister
hat das direkte und aus der nähe erlebt
im jahr 2019 vor der pandemie haben wir
es geschafft
50,9 prozent schuldenstand solange es
ist gelungen in einem jahrzehnt von 80
auf unter 60 zu kommen und nur dadurch
dass das passiert ist ist es auch
gelungen dass wir in der pandemie die
finanziellen möglichkeiten hatten dann
expansiv zu reagieren der zusammenhang
ist klar die schuldenbremse schütz
handlungsfähigkeit und auch thesen
fähigkeit des staates in der zukunft und
natürlich
und natürlich ist es richtig dass die
herausforderungen heute multipel sind
die krisen sind multipel wir haben eine
pandemie die in einer anderen phase ist
als noch vor einem jahr aber die noch da
ist die aufmerksamkeit erfordert wir
haben die herausforderung des krieges
der inflation und die aufgabe sehr
schnell auch unseren co2 ausstoß
abzusenken plus einen großen
investitionsbedarf das ist unbestritten
aber keine dieser herausforderung
verschwindet in einem jahr oder in zwei
jahren es sind alles staatliche dauer
aufgaben und deshalb ist es auch wichtig
und nötig diese staatlichen
daueraufgaben auch strukturell in den
haushalt ein zu arbeiten genau darum
geht es jetzt um genau dafür ist der
haushalt 23 und der mit vorgelegte
finanzplan auch der richtige schritt und
eines wird oft auch vergessen die
schuldenbremse wenn man sie wenn man sie
aussetzt führt dazu dass man erst mal
mehr ausgeben kann aber es wird auch
dazu dass später mehr gezählt werden
muss und auch das ist ein argument dafür
wenn wir wissen dass das daueraufgaben
sind dass wir sie früher einhalten dann
müssen wir später weniger tilgen und
haben größere handlungsspielräume
insofern
insofern ist es wichtig dass wir diese
regel jetzt wieder einhalten und ich
will auch sehr deutlich sagen die
entlastungsmaßnahmen die ich gerade
angesprochen habe die wir gemeinsam am
wochenende beschlossen haben die ob ich
eine starke wirkung auch haben werden
sind mit diesem zielen vereinbar wir
haben im laufenden haushaltsjahr
spielräume dadurch dass wir sparsam
gewirtschaftet haben sie haben höhere
steuereinnahmen absehbar in diesem jahr
und auch im nächsten jahr die wir
zurückgeben können und auch zurückgeben
wollen und wir haben vorsorge wir haben
bereits vorsorge im regierungsentwurf
2023 geschaffen auch und gerade für
entlastungsmaßnahmen die wir nutzen
können insofern steckt nach unserer
auffassung decken die entlass sind die
entlastungen die beschlossen worden sind
mit der schuldenbremse mit dem ziel sie
wieder einzuhalten für den bund
vereinbare ich will aber auch sehr
deutlich sagen mehr zu tun ist im bund
nicht möglich es ist jetzt das was wir
leisten können und auch leisten
ich möchte
zum abschluss noch auf einige
schwerpunkte in diesem haushalt eingehen
weil auch deutlich ist dass wir in
krisenzeiten sehr wohl in sehr vielen
politikfeldern schwerpunkte setzen und
auch neue projekte beginnen können die
schuldenbremse ist weder investitions
noch innovationsbremse man sieht das an
investitions etwa die
investitionsausgaben des bundes bleiben
auf rekordniveau wir haben mit 51
milliarden euro einen sehr hohen wert
für investitionen dahinter verbergen
sich natürlich vor allem
verkehrsinvestitionen wobei mehr geld in
die schiene als in die straße fließt wir
haben zukunftsprojekte im bereich
mikroelektronik von über vier milliarden
euro auch ein stück autonomie ein stück
unabhängigkeit wir haben hohe
investitionen in klima und
transformation fonds für
wasserstoffwirtschaft e mobilität und
auch gebäudesanierung wo wir stark
steigende nachfrage angesichts der
aktuellen situation beobachten
deutschland investiert der bund
investiert und kommt damit seinen
aufgaben und verpflichtungen auch in
vollem umfang nach wir haben im bereich
und forschung ebenfalls wachsende
plattform natürlich ist das etwas was
auch gar nicht für die zukunft unseres
landes sehr sehr wichtig ist wir werden
insgesamt im finanzplanungszeitraum etwa
vier milliarden euro mehr für bildung
und forschung ausgeben können als noch
in der vorherigen finanzplan angesetzt
zum beispiel für leistungsverbesserungen
beim bafög und eine stärkung der mission
orientierten forschung wir geben geld
aus selbstverständlich auch für die
stärkung des sozialen zusammenhalts
wir werden im sozialen wohnungsbau
beispielsweise den ländern steigende
mittel zur verfügung stellen um diese
aufgabe auch wahrnehmen zu können und
ihren beitrag leisten zu können für die
für das ziel 400.000 wohnungen davon
100.000 öffentlich geförderte pro jahr
zu realisieren
wir werben
die gesetzliche rentenversicherung
weiterhin mit großen summen unterstützen
112 milliarden euro sind das im
kommenden jahres wird ansteigen bis zum
jahr 2026 auf 128 8 milliarden euro und
wir werben wir werden weil die
gesetzliche krankenversicherung
in einem zustand übergeben worden ist
der ausgesprochen um es nett
auszudrücken reformbedürftig
auch seitens des bundeshaushalts
zusätzlich nochmal zwei milliarden euro
als zuschuss und eine milliarde euro als
darlehen in ein gutes gesundheitssystem
stecken das sind dinge die wir machen
weil sie richtig sind weil sie den
alltag der bürgerinnen und bürger
betreffen und die sind auch möglich auch
in den zeiten die wir momentan haben wir
haben ansonsten selbstverständlich auch
riesige herausforderungen im
internationalen bereich wir haben uns
darauf verständigt für die
internationale klimafinanzierung
2023 4 milliarden euro beizutragen wir
haben auch die sogenannten oder
maßnahmen also die maßnahmen für
öffentliche entwicklungszusammenarbeit
einschließlich humanitärer hilfe
fortgeschrieben auf über 22 milliarden
euro deutschland wird auch im kommenden
jahr nach den usa weltweit der größte
geber sein und nach allem was wir
voraussagen können werden wir auch die
0,7 prozent oder quote die das ziel sind
dass in diesem bereich gilt auch
einhalten können mit dem
haushaltsentwurf den wir vorgelegt haben
das ist ein wichtiges signal nicht
angesprochen hunger als waffe ist er ist
auch ein teil dessen was putin macht und
insofern sind wir gefordert uns auch
entsprechend einzubringen so wie es
deutschlands rolle in der welt gewählt
wir werden nachdem wir
im frühjahr vom sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr beschließen konnten auch den
verteidigungsetat fortschreiben mit 50,1
milliarden euro das ist übrigens drei
milliarden mehr als die letzte
finanzplanung der regierung merkel für
dieses jahr eingeplant hatte drei
milliarden mehr im
einzelplan 14 für die bundeswehr und
eine zeitenwende herr kollege frei ich
dachte jetzt sind sie zufrieden denn sie
haben ja immer gesagt die bundeswehr
sollen mehr bekommen und wir blieben
immerhin mehr als drei milliarden mehr
als sie noch vor einem jahr
vorgeschlagen haben ich finde das ist
eigentlich ein ziemlich guter schritt
zumal die
finanziellen rahmenbedingungen ja nicht
einfacher geworden sind in der zeit das
sondervermögen die 100 milliarden euro
werden schrittweise natürlich
abschließend in dem maße in dem auch
lieferungen von entsprechenden
militärischen geräten erfolgen wir
rechnen damit dass das zusätzlich zum 19
14 nächstes jahr 8,5 milliarden euro
etwa betragen wird man muss aber sagen
der besondere nutzen diese
sondervermögens liegt ja gerade darin
dass die bundeswehr mit dem budget von
100 milliarden euro sofort planen kann
und sofort parallel beschaffen kann und
insofern sind wir sehr froh dass wir
diese möglichkeit haben jetzt auf einen
schlag und damit auch systematisch die
streitkräfte so zu modernisieren wie es
auch vorher schon richtig gewesen wäre
die kolleginnen und kollegen es ist
ohne jede frage eine
herausfordernde umgebung es ist auch
nicht so dass es für alle diese themen
leichte lösungen geben würde oder dass
das hier jemand so vortragen würde es
gibt auseinandersetzungen zu führen es
gibt auch dinge abzuwägen dieser
haushalt bringt sehr viele ziele die wir
verfolgen
krisenbewältigung aber auch den blick in
die zukunft investitionen soziales
infrastruktur zusammen er ist ein gut
eine gute grundlage für die
parlamentarischen beratungen davon bin
ich überzeugt
selbstverständlich gerade in der
jetzigen umgebung wird es auch noch
dinge geben die geändert die
eingearbeitet werden müssen
einschließlich der beschlüsse des
letzten wochenendes zu entlastungen das
ist selbstverständlich aber ich meine
der haushalt zeigt dieses land hat
enorme ressourcen wenn dieses land es
schafft seinen start klug einzusetzen
seine staatlichen mittel klug
einzusetzen und gleichzeitig auch die
kraft der gesellschaft vertraut dann
können wir auch diese bewährungsprobe in
der wir sind meistern so ähnlich meine
ich würden auch die menschen in israel
mit dieser situation umgehen machen wir
uns das zu eigen und nehmen wir diese
aufgaben an ich danke ihnen sehr
herzlich
[Applaus]